the food scene in New York has changed
come you know completely it's gone
through a couple different things I mean
when I came to New York there were seven
eight restaurants if you were serious
cook to eat at most of them French I
think you know David Burke was at river
cafe Charlotte Palmer just opened a
boreal boules just got four stars at
blade and they were really the three
American guys at the time that were just
started to kind of like do something and
then they were all the French there was
lack Abbas there was all the quilted
wrappers around the Cirque that whole
scene now it's it's unbelievable I mean
there's a lot of good restaurants around
town restaurants good restaurants that
are doing a Tundra covers ingly
restaurants that are cooking for 80
people there's chefs from all over the
world now that have come to New York
there's a you know small little places
that are great there's a lot of great
ethnic food also you mean you can go you
know go all over the boroughs and get
you know some pretty good ethnic food so
it's changed like it's pretty
unbelievable so if I was a young cook
coming to New York and you know people
we have that stodger in our kitchen we
have a couple every week and I always
ask the first question asked is like so
where else you where else you looking at
working and it's the variety is just
unbelievable to say well i'm looking at
Danielle and I'm thinking about going to
momofuku but maybe I'll go to the little
owl and maybe I'll go to Morimoto I mean
how different can you get as far as
ambience price point style of cuisine
it's just it's pretty amazing
I mean everyone everyone always asks
well how many more restaurants can you
know New York City take my answers that
is you know if you go to Tokyo you could
live in Tokyo your whole life and have
lunch and dinner at a different
restaurant every single day and never
ever ever repeat and you know New York
are always change and I'll always be
like those iconic favorites will always
be like the hot new spot and they're
always be you know something coming in
something going so that's gonna that's
always going to change you know one
thing that has changed is the kind of
think it's the class division as it
relates to restaurants has really
changed and there's a lot of
transparency between you know high-end
four-star places and like the little
place at a corner I remember I remember
a chef that will go in named was
complaining one day he that we were
trying to get fresh porcini mushrooms
and this is in the mid-90s we were
trying to get it we're on the phone
we're trying to get some from the market
and the purveyor just ran out of these
mushrooms and there was some discussion
because I think there was a party that
requested them and it was a restaurant
that was downtown and just opened back
when there weren't restaurants downtown
or maybe there were two or three and it
was a French chef that was yelling and
screaming like how can these guys open
up these restaurants downtown and take
porcini mushrooms because they shouldn't
be taking porcini mushrooms they should
be cooking hamburgers and that's changed
because you can go down Avenue A or you
can go to le s so you could go to west
village or you can go the on Smith
Street and you can probably find some
wild mushrooms on the menu so that's
really changed is that kind of like the
high-end ingredients have made the way
to the neighborhood restaurants and the
lower end ingredients have made the way
to the higher end restaurants you know
you have pigs feet
sat Danielle and you'll have veal head
at per se and that's a pretty
interesting phenomena I mean the
casualness is really is is well you have
classically trained guys are like
high-end guys that have done more casual
stuff I mean I it's it's funny with me
you know I met someone who doesn't have
a restaurant now but what's around New
York for you know a long time and I met
her for the first time three months ago
and she thought I was Italian she didn't
know that I was American because we've
never met before but she just assumed
cuz you know she might have glanced and
something about me that said France and
said in Italy and said some fancy
restaurants and assume that I was
European and that blew me away a little
bit I think that you know and I'm not so
inspired for myself really to do
high-end cooking anymore at you know at
this point for myself and I let you know
it we're a vote she is i don't think
i'll go in a higher level than that
again I want to do different levels of
stuff moving on just because that's the
way I've been eating lately
by travelpod member